what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we have some insanely huge news
about The Flash movie today it looks
like the true main villain for this
movie who has sort of been a mystery up
until this point has been revealed and
it looks like a lot of DC fans may not
be too excited about what is about to
happen in The Flash Film in fact many
are already kind of upset but with James
Gunn and Peter saffron taking over DC
and basically doing a reboot of the
former Justice League The Flash included
this doesn't really come as too big of a
surprise but it looks like reverse flash
could be completely cut from the film
and a new villain could be taken his
place and that new villain is dark flash
we have discovered this thanks to a
recent toy leak and there are more
reveals than just the villain for
example it showed one toy labeled as the
flash young Berry this was once thought
to be a multiversal variant of The Flash
but that may not actually be the case it
may just be a young Barry Allen
traveling forward in time or Barry Allen
simply traveling backwards in time to
see a younger version of himself I'm
sure we will see some variants at some
point in time in the movie however what
we believe to be this variant before
simply seems to be a younger Berry but
with this leak we also see the regular
Flash costume Michael Keaton's Batman
and then we see what is labeled as dark
flash donning a black suit with spikes
coming out of it now little is known
about dark flash on the role that this
character is going to play in the
upcoming film it does of course seem
like they're going to be the main
villain now there is a character called
black flash in the comics that this
character definitely resembles in the
comics the black flash returns a
Speedster to the speed force an extra
dimensional force of cosmic energy from
which all of these speedsters get their
powers from and upon their deaths black
flash appears shortly before a Speedster
is about to die now I know there's been
a lot of controversy around Ezra Miller
lately and of course like I mentioned
James Gunn is going to be rebooting the
old Justice League and he's confirmed
that the new Justice League characters
that are coming in like Superman are
going to be younger so could we see the
death of The Flash in this film if the
dark flash character is based off of the
black flash character from the comics
it's looking like that definitely could
be possible however of course there is
time travel involved in this movie and
the Multiverse as well so it doesn't
actually mean the main flash could die
and even if he does that could be
reversed anything is kind of possible
with the Multiverse and time travel
however though with the reverse flash
probably being cut out of this
completely that does kind of eliminate
the flashpoint storyline which this
movie was said to be based off of and
this is what can kind of irritate some
fans out there right now now this movie
was kind of up in the air to begin with
especially with everything that Ezra
Miller was going through and now we've
heard that they've been doing some
reshoots but perhaps they do you have a
plan we do know that the original Flash
movie was supposed to set up the old DC
Multiverse since we're getting a reboot
that probably isn't the case anymore so
perhaps they're just trying to end this
movie and not have it set up anything
which unfortunately could result in the
death of The Flash but hey let me know
your thoughts about this in the comments
down below how do you feel about this
how do you feel about reverse flash
possibly being cut well probably being
cut and the whole Flashpoint storyline
kind of going away possibly and of
course let us know your thoughts on dark
flash in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
stay up to date on the latest DC news
for live updates you can follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof